good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
about The Fault in Our Stars movie also
today's video will be a response to your
video from Friday but it's gonna take me
a minute so let's get right to it
when you were writing The Fault in Our
Stars did you ever think it would become
a movie no I mean when was the last time
you saw a movie in which the leading
lady has nasal canula in every scene of
the film it does not happen Hollywood
doesn't usually make like love stories
about disabled teenagers so no I didn't
think it would happen but I'm delighted
did you really cry a lot while you were
on the movie set yes why
well no spoilers but but it turns out
that there's some sad parts John are you
gonna be in the movie yes unless my
scene gets cut I have a really important
role but I'm not allowed to tell you
what it is yet was that your first time
ever acting I'm not sure I would go what
I did
acting now that you've acted in a movie
would you ever consider a career in
movies or television is a question that
people will not be asking me after they
see the movie hey do you have an
official release date that I can put on
my calendar and scream about yes the
movie comes out on June 6th at least in
the US I don't know about international
yet you don't have to scream but you
should put it on your calendar because
these days the success of a movie is
judged largely on how many people see it
in like the first 24 hours why is the
premiere date so far away well it's not
that far away I mean they just been a
shooting it five days ago and now they
have to edit it which is when it really
becomes a movie and that takes a long
time it's not like getting a blog
brothers video but yeah they're waiting
til June because it's difficult summer
blockbuster fare you know it's like Iron
Man 4 but without Robert Downey jr. or
Iron Men how does it feel to be a
big-time movie producer making the big
bucks well for the record I am NOT a
movie producer big time or otherwise The
Fault in Our Stars movie is not my movie
like I'm not a director or a producer or
a casting director or a music supervisor
and God knows I am NOT an actor
well choice Ivan song about Tippi Osby
on the soundtrack yeah that's another
example of a decision I will not be
making although I do love that song is
the movie the exact same as the book no
the movie is made out of like pictures
and sound whereas the book is made
entirely of scratches on a page so I
don't think that can be the same and I
also don't think they should be because
in a movie you're trying to tell a
visual story instead of a textual story
that said I think the movie script was a
very faithful adaptation one of the most
faithful I've ever read then again when
I had the opportunity to adapt my own
novel Paper Towns into a screenplay I
had the main character pursue an
entirely different girl than he does in
the book so I might not be the best
mayor of faithful adaptation town should
I read the book before seeing the movie
or the other way around oh you should
definitely read it first said the
totally unbiased observer be honest how
were the kissing scenes a plus plus plus
very good would watch again since it was
filmed in Pittsburgh how did the movie
recreate things that are specific to
Indianapolis like funky bones everything
was recreated by amazing set designers
so like funky bones was recreated with
help from the artist and also from my
wife who helped curate the project and
then Sara flew it to Pittsburgh for
funky bones day to make sure that
everything looked right and it really
did like even from 6 inches away I could
not tell that I wasn't looking at the
real funky bones sorry for the double
negative by the way did I tell you that
Sara's leaving her job at the
Indianapolis Museum of Art in order to
curate and host a show with PBS Digital
called the art assignment link in the
doobly-doo
yeah I'm sorry I should have mentioned
that weeks ago terrible husbanding what
do you think about people saying
Shailene is too attractive to play hazel
well I'm offended on Hazel's behalf when
in the book does it ever say she's not
attractive she's very attractive did you
have any preconceived ideas about movies
that got blown out of the water yeah on
some level I always thought that movies
were really about like actors and
directors and producers maybe a
cinematographer I never really
understood how all those people who are
listed at the end of the credits are
absolutely vital to the creation of a
movie that massive collaboration
involving hundreds of people is what
makes movies possible and it's also why
I would argue that curiosity is not the
most important human trait the urge to
collaborate is Hank I would argue that
lots of animals are really curious but
only we have the ability to cooperate to
make like online communities and space
telescopes and imagine areum's and
movies so the great thrill of this whole
experience for me was seeing humanity do
what I think its best at which
ultimately is not competing but
cooperating although of course we do
compete a lot so yeah I disagree with
you I think it's cooperation not
curiosity I might be wrong you're
usually right you're probably right but
I started I think my I think what I
think I'll see you on Friday